Die Krylow-Quanten-Diagonalisierung, kurz KQD, bezeichnet die Lösung eines Matrixeigenwertproblems
durch Projektion der Matrix auf einen Unterraum, der auf einem Quantencomputer vorbereitet wird – in Übereinstimmung mit der Krylow-Methode, einem
leistungsstarken Ansatz aus der klassischen linearen Algebra. In diesem Video erkunden wir, wofür die Krylow-Methode nützlich ist
und wie und wann du sie auf Quantencomputern einsetzen kannst.
Was ist also die Krylow-Methode? Angenommen, wir haben eine Matrix H, die mit einem wissenschaftlichen oder geschäftlichen Problem zusammenhängt, mit n Zeilen und n
Spalten. Uns interessiert der kleinste Eigenwert e₀ und der zugehörige Eigenvektor ψ₀. Definieren wir einen
Startvektor v, der entweder durch die Struktur von H motiviert sein kann oder völlig zufällig gewählt wird. Der Krylow-Unterraum
der Ordnung r, den wir K_r schreiben, wird erzeugt, indem H auf diesen
Startvektor r minus eins Mal angewendet wird und das Ergebnis jeder weiteren H-Anwendung
zur Menge der Aufspannvektoren hinzugefügt wird – das heißt, K_r ist der von den Vektoren v,
Hv, H²v und so weiter aufgespannte Raum. Diese Vektoren sind im Allgemeinen nicht orthogonal.
Klassisch führen wir oft einen Orthogonalisierungsprozess durch, ähnlich dem Gram-Schmidt-Verfahren. Du beginnst
damit, den Startvektor V zu normieren, und nennst das Ergebnis V₀. Für den nächsten Vektor HV subtrahierst du dann seine
Projektion auf V₀, um die beiden Vektoren orthogonal zu machen, und normierst das Ergebnis anschließend. Du machst so weiter,
indem du erneut mit H wirkst und das Ergebnis orthogonal zu allen zuvor hinzugefügten Vektoren machst, bis du R
orthonormierte Vektoren aufgebaut hast, die deinen R-dimensionalen Krylow-Unterraum aufspannen.
Sobald du diesen Unterraum hast, projizierst du deine Matrix darauf und diagonalisierst die kleinere projizierte Matrix. Es gibt
Feinheiten und Erweiterungen, aber das ist die Krylow-Methode auf ihrer einfachsten Ebene.
Um ein besseres Gefühl dafür zu bekommen, wie das funktioniert, schauen wir uns ein einfaches Beispiel an. Wenn H diese Matrix ist und V so gewählt wird,
dann würden wir zunächst V normieren. Um den zweiten Vektor im Krylow-Unterraum zu erzeugen, wenden wir
H einmal auf unseren Startvektor an und machen das Ergebnis dann orthogonal zu V₀.
Ein bisschen Algebra liefert dieses Ergebnis für V₁.
Das ist für so kleine Matrizen nicht sinnvoll und man würde normalerweise nicht bei einer Krylow-Dimension von zwei aufhören. Aber wenn wir
H auf unseren neuen Krylow-Raum K₂ projizieren wollten, würden wir das mit einer Matrix V tun,
die einen Krylow-Vektor pro Spalte hat, und ihrem transponierten Konjugat, das Krylow-Vektoren als Zeilen enthält. Wir würden dann
diese Matrix erhalten.
Diese Matrix hat technisch gesehen eine geringere Dimension als unsere ursprüngliche. Offensichtlich ist diese Reduktion in diesem
Maßstab nicht nützlich. Diese Methode ist dafür gedacht, Matrizen mit vielen Tausend oder sogar Millionen von Zeilen und Spalten
auf nur eine Handvoll zu reduzieren. Warum sind Krylow-Methoden also nützlich? Es stellt sich heraus, dass diese einfache Vorschrift
der Operatoranwendung oft der effizienteste Weg ist, sich dem Zustand mit dem niedrigsten Eigenwert, dem Grundzustand einer Matrix,
anzunähern. Lass uns das etwas expliziter machen, auch wenn wir den vollständigen Beweis dem begleitenden Text überlassen. Wir möchten
ein Problem der Form H angewendet auf den Vektor x lösen, das uns eine Konstante mal den Vektor x ergibt. Beginnen wir mit einer
Schätzung unseres Eigenvektors x₀. Das ist nur eine Näherungslösung. Sie hat einen Fehler, den wir e₀ nennen. Jetzt möchten wir
eine Aktualisierung dieser Schätzung vornehmen, die wir x₁ nennen und die unsere Näherung verbessern soll. Wir können das ausdrücken als
das ursprüngliche x₀ plus eine Korrektur p₀, die noch zu bestimmen ist. Wir können
diesen Prozess iterativ wiederholen und immer mehr Korrektionsvektoren pᵢ hinzufügen.
Natürlich wollen wir, dass unser Fehler reduziert wird, aber nicht nur der Zustand selbst ist uns wichtig. Uns interessiert auch die
Wirkung von H auf diesen Zustand. Die Größe, die wir wirklich minimieren wollen, ist die H-Norm dieses Fehlers, also die Norm der
Wirkung von H auf diesen Fehler.
Jetzt sehen wir, dass dies ein Ausdruck ist, der p₀ enthält, und wir können uns fragen, welche Wahl von p diese
H-Norm des Fehlers am effizientesten minimiert. Aus welchem Raum sollen wir die Korrektur wählen? Unter bestimmten
Bedingungen – zum Beispiel wenn H symmetrisch und positiv definit ist – ist es optimal, die ersten r Korrektionen aus K_r zu wählen.
Einfacher ausgedrückt: Wir brauchen eine Möglichkeit, einen guten Unterraum vorzubereiten, auf den wir
unseren Hamiltonoperator projizieren können. Und in vielen Fällen ist der Krylow-Unterraum der Raum, der von den Vektoren der
effizientesten Korrektionen zu unserer Anfangsschätzung aufgespannt wird.
Für einen echten Beweis schau dir den Text zu diesem Video an.
Alles, was wir bisher beschrieben haben, kann klassisch durchgeführt werden. Wie und wann würden wir also einen Quantencomputer einsetzen?
Bei sehr großen Matrizen kann die Krylow-Methode lange Rechenzeiten und große Speichermengen erfordern. Die Zeit,
die für die Matrixoperation H angewendet auf V benötigt wird, skaliert im schlechtesten Fall wie N².
Und das geschieht für jeden Vektor, den wir in unserem Unterraum haben wollen. Die Unterraumdimension R ist normalerweise kein wesentlicher
Bruchteil von N und skaliert oft wie log N. Das Erzeugen aller Vektoren skaliert also
wie O(N² log N).
Obwohl es weitere Schritte wie die Orthogonalisierung gibt, ist das die dominante Skalierung, die man im Kopf behalten sollte.
Quantencomputing ermöglicht es uns, zu verändern, welche Eigenschaften des Problems die Skalierung von Zeit und Ressourcen bestimmen.
Anstatt durchgehend von der Matrixgröße n abzuhängen, werden wir Dinge wie die Anzahl der Shots und
die Anzahl der nicht-kommutierenden Pauli-Terme sehen, aus denen ein Hamiltonoperator besteht.
Lass uns erkunden, wie das funktioniert.
Erinnere dich, dass der Operator, der einen Quantenzustand zeitlich entwickelt, das Exponential von iH geteilt durch ħ ist. Und es ist
sehr verbreitet, vor allem im Quantencomputing, ħ in der Notation wegzulassen.
Eine Möglichkeit, eine solche Exponentialfunktion eines Operators zu verstehen und sogar zu realisieren, ist ihre Fourier-
Reihenentwicklung zu betrachten. Beachte, dass diese Operation, angewendet auf einen Startvektor V, eine Summe von Termen
mit zunehmenden Potenzen von H, angewendet auf den Anfangszustand, ergibt. Es sieht so aus, als könnten wir unseren Krylow-Unterraum einfach durch Zeitentwicklung
unseres Anfangszustands erzeugen. Und das stimmt fast. Der Vorbehalt liegt in der
Realisierung der Zeitentwicklung auf einem echten Quantencomputer. Viele der Terme im Hamiltonoperator kommutieren nicht
miteinander. Während also einige einfache Exponentialoperatoren wie e hoch minus iZ einfachen
circuits entsprechen, gilt das für allgemeine Hamiltonoperatoren nicht, da sie nicht-kommutierende Terme enthalten
und wir das Exponential daher nicht einfach in ein Produkt einfacher Exponentialfunktionen zerlegen können, wie wir es mit Zahlen tun könnten. Das
ist also nicht trivial, aber es handelt sich um einen gut untersuchten Prozess im Quantencomputing. Wir führen die Zeitentwicklung
auf Quantencomputern mithilfe eines Verfahrens namens Trotterisierung, was an sich schon ein reichhaltiges Thema ist. Aber auf einem sehr hohen Niveau
indem wir die Zeitentwicklung in kleine Schritte – sagen wir M Schritte – aufteilen, begrenzen wir die Auswirkungen der Nicht-Kommutativität von
Termen. Nennen wir den Krylov-Unterraum der Ordnung r, den wir im klassischen Kontext mithilfe von Potenzen von H erzeugt haben,
direkt den Potenz-Krylov-Unterraum KPr.
Nun erzeugen wir einen ähnlichen Raum mithilfe des unitären Zeitentwicklungsoperators U, der durch den Exponentialausdruck von iHt gegeben ist.
Wir bezeichnen diesen als den unitären Krylov-Raum KUr.
Der Potenz-Krylov-Unterraum KPr, den wir klassisch verwenden, kann auf einem Quantencomputer nicht direkt erzeugt werden, da H
kein unitärer Operator ist. Es lässt sich zeigen, dass die Verwendung des unitären Krylov-Unterraums ähnliche Konvergenz-
garantien liefert wie der Potenz-Krylov-Unterraum.
Der Grundzustandsfehler konvergiert insbesondere dann effizient, wenn der Anfangszustand V eine Überlappung mit dem
wahren Grundzustand aufweist, die nicht exponentiell gegen null geht, und solange eine ausreichende Lücke zwischen Eigen-
zuständen besteht. Hier werden Potenzen von U zu verschiedenen Zeitschritten. Die k-te Potenz von U entspricht einem Vorwärtsschritt
um eine Zeit k * dt.
Wir können das Element des Unterraums, das für eine Gesamtzeit kdt zeitentwickelt wurde, als s_k bezeichnen. Wir können unseren
Hamiltonian H auf den unitären Krylov-Unterraum KUr projizieren. Mit anderen Worten:
Wir berechnen jedes Matrixelement von H in der KUr-Basis. Wir bezeichnen diese
projizierte Matrix als H-Tilde. Die Matrixelemente von H-Tilde sind durch diese Erwartungswerte gegeben, die mithilfe des
Quantencomputers geschätzt werden können.
Denk daran, dass H als Summe von Pauli-Operatoren auf verschiedenen qubits geschrieben werden kann und dass nicht alle Pauli-Operatoren
gleichzeitig gemessen werden können. Wir können die Pauli-Terme in Gruppen kommutierender Terme einteilen und alle
davon auf einmal messen. Aber wir brauchen möglicherweise viele solcher Gruppen, um alle Terme abzudecken. Daher wird die Anzahl der verschiedenen kommutierenden Gruppen, in die
die Terme aufgeteilt werden können – NGCP –, wichtig. Wenn wir einen unitären Krylov-Unterraum der Dimension r verwenden,
hat die resultierende Matrix die Dimensionen r * r. Wenn r viel kleiner als N ist, haben wir
nützliche Fortschritte erzielt, und typischerweise ist r weit kleiner als 100, was bedeutet, dass wir diese Matrix problemlos auf einem klassischen
Computer diagonalisieren können. Aber denk daran, dass s_n und s_m im Allgemeinen nicht orthogonal sein werden. Es ist
manchmal möglich, eine Matrix in einer nicht-orthogonalen Basis zu diagonalisieren. Aber es gibt numerische und physikalische Gründe,
zunächst zu einer orthogonalen Basis zu wechseln. Daher lösen wir ein verallgemeinertes Eigenwertproblem mithilfe der Gram-Matrix S.
Das mn-Element der Gram-Matrix ist durch das Innenprodukt von s_m und s_n gegeben.
Sowohl die Elemente von H-Tilde als auch von S werden mithilfe eines Hadamard-Tests berechnet.
Das verallgemeinerte Eigenwertproblem lautet dann wie folgt.
Wie oben erwähnt, ist die Dimension des unitären Krylov-Unterraums R exponentiell kleiner als unsere ursprüngliche
Matrixdimension N. Dieses Eigenwertproblem ist daher klassisch einfach zu lösen.
Zur Zusammenfassung: Wir beginnen mit einem Referenzzustand und entwickeln ihn dann für verschiedene Zeitspannen, um den unitären
Krylov-Unterraum zu erzeugen. Wir projizieren unseren Hamiltonian auf diesen Unterraum und schätzen auch die Überlappungen der
Unterraumvektoren. Schließlich lösen wir das niedrigdimensionale verallgemeinerte Eigenwertproblem klassisch. Vergleichen wir nun, was
den Rechenaufwand bei der klassischen und der quantenmechanischen Anwendung der Krylov-Methode bestimmt. Wir haben dies
bereits für die klassische Version skizziert, und es gibt keine perfekten Entsprechungen zwischen klassischen und quantenmechanischen Ansätzen für alle Schritte. Aber diese Tabelle fasst einige
Skalierungen verschiedener Schritte zur Überlegung zusammen. Denk daran, dass Hamiltonians im Allgemeinen Terme haben, die nicht gleichzeitig gemessen werden können, weil sie
nicht kommutieren. Wir teilen die Terme des Hamiltonians in Gruppen kommutierender Pauli-Operatoren ein, die alle gleichzeitig gemessen werden können, und wir brauchen möglicherweise viele
solcher Gruppen, um alle nicht-kommutierenden Terme zu berücksichtigen. Um H-Tilde auf einem Quantencomputer aufzubauen, sind
separate Messungen für jede Gruppe kommutierender Pauli-Strings im Hamiltonian erforderlich. Und jede davon erfordert viele Shots. Dies müssen wir für R
quadrat verschiedene Matrixelemente tun, die R-Quadrat-Kombinationen verschiedener Zeitentwicklungsfaktoren entsprechen.
Es gibt manchmal Möglichkeiten, dies zu reduzieren. Aber in dieser groben Behandlung skaliert der dafür benötigte Zeitaufwand ungefähr wie
die Anzahl der Shots mal die Anzahl der Gruppen kommutierender Pauli-Terme mal r^2.
Die Elemente von S müssen geschätzt werden, was wie die Anzahl der Shots
hoch drei skaliert. Wir sehen, dass die quantenmechanische Krylov-Diagonalisierung in Fällen nützlich sein kann, in denen die Anzahl der kommutierenden Pauli-
Gruppen im Hamiltonian relativ gering ist.
Diese Skalierungsabhängigkeit deutet auf einige Anwendungen hin, bei denen die Krylov-Methode nützlich sein kann, und andere, bei denen sie es wahrscheinlich
nicht sein wird. Manche Hamiltonians weisen bei der Abbildung auf qubits eine hohe Komplexität auf und beinhalten viele nicht-kommutierende Pauli-Strings,
die sich nicht leicht in wenige kommutierende Gruppen aufteilen lassen.
Das trifft häufig auf Quantenchemieprobleme zu. Diese Komplexität stellt beispielsweise zwei grundlegende Herausforderungen für
Quantencomputer der nahen Zukunft dar. Erstens wird die Schätzung jedes Elements von H-Tilde aufgrund der
großen Anzahl von Termen rechenintensiv. Zweitens werden die erforderlichen Trotter-circuits unvertretbar tief. Beide Punkte
werden weniger problematisch, wenn Quantencomputer fehlertoleranz erreichen, müssen aber kurzfristig berücksichtigt werden. Sogar Systeme mit einfacheren Abbildungen
als in der Quantenchemie können auf dieselben Hindernisse stoßen, wenn die Hamiltonians zu viele nicht-kommutierende
Terme haben. Die Krylov-Methode ist am nützlichsten, wenn der Hamiltonian in relativ wenige kommutierende Pauli-
Gruppen aufgeteilt werden kann und H sich leicht in Trotter-circuits implementieren lässt. Beide Bedingungen sind erfüllt. Zum
Beispiel für viele Gittermodelle von Interesse in der Physik ist KQD besonders nützlich, wenn sehr wenig über den
Grundzustand bekannt ist. Das liegt an den inhärenten Konvergenzgarantien und seiner Anwendbarkeit in Szenarien, in denen
alternative Methoden aufgrund unzureichender Grundzustandskenntnis nicht anwendbar sind.
Obwohl KQD ein leistungsstarkes Werkzeug ist, stellen die zeitaufwändigen Aspekte des Protokolls – insbesondere die Schätzung jedes
Elements des projizierten Hamiltonians und die Überlappung der Krylov-Zustände – Verbesserungsmöglichkeiten dar.
Ein alternativer Ansatz besteht darin, den Krylov-Zustand mithilfe von Trotter-circuits zu approximieren und dann den
approximierten Zustand zu sampeln, um eine Projektion auf die Rechenbasis zu erhalten, und dann H auf den Unterraum zu projizieren,
der von diesen Rechenbasiszuständen aufgespannt wird.
In Fällen, in denen es anwendbar ist, bietet diese Methodik – bekannt als sampling-basierte Krylov-Quanten-Diagonalisierung SKQD –
möglicherweise erhebliche Reduktionen beim Zeit- und Ressourcenaufwand im Vergleich zum traditionellen KQD.
Die Integration von Krylov-Unterraumtechniken mit Sampling-Methoden in SKQD stellt eine spannende Grenze der
Quantenalgorithmen dar.